The joe rogan experience were bananas.
It's crazy.
And then you know what it is though.
Here's the real victims of ending the drug war would be all those prisons that
would no longer be full of young black men.
You say this,
but what if your business is running prisons,
right?
I mean it's your business is prison guards.
I mean that's
someone think of the prison,
the prison industrial complex prison guards lobby against drug legalizations
cause do it because they want to stay in office.
They want to keep their jobs and how many lives has to be ruined in the process.
Fucking crazy to vampire system.
So horrible vampire system and it's a system that's brought out of it's,
it's based on these reverberations are these vibrations from the past.
It's all like this scramble when a people were retarded,
when they came over on boats and this is just how they did things.
They throw in a jail,
he'll fucking scoundrel.
You were smoking marijuana or whatever.
The rule that you broke is that they realize that they can do it.
So they do do it and they throw you in some fucking cage in 2014 the fact that
that's still going on and that people are actually profiting from it.
This is,
these are more things that the Internet has a huge fucking problem with.
Cause the Internet's guys like you is young fellas that are very smart and
unconventional and seeing the system and being like,
you know what?
I don't buy it.
I think a,
there's shit that people I knew growing up that were adults,
I knew they were fucking idiots and they knew they made bad choices.
And now I'm looking at the,
the repercussions of this everywhere.
I'm looking at an item saying,
no,
this is dumb.
This is,
so this is one of the things,
especially talking to college students that I love bringing up,
which is that,
and I'm the first to admit that like I have no fucking clue what I'm doing.
99% of the time eat.
Especially when I got started,
I still don't know.
And I've,
I've come to realize like I've got,
I've got been lucky enough to meet some pretty like successful,
impressive people.
But like you dig under the surface,
we're all just hacking it.
Like we're all just figure,
expertise,
experience those things.
I'll help.
But like every one of us is a fallible human,
all the conventions and rules and status quo we know were created by other
fallible humans.
And there's no reason not to look at that and go,
Huh,
does it have to be that way?
Or why is it that way?
And if the reason why is low,
that's the way it is.
Well that's a terrible reason,
you know?
And,
and when you see the world as being that hackable,
so to speak,
like you start to realize,
all right,
well let's just,
let's actually question stuff.
And,
and for,
you know,
I remember I was a freshman at Uva when nine 11 happened for this generation of
millennials coming up.
We mow nearly all of us.
One of our first really vivid memories of the world was nine 11 this awful
tragedy.
And then we get into these two wars and then think of all the authority figures
we've had in our life since that moment.
They've all at one point,
other either misled us,
this sort of deceived us.
Um,
you've got the financial crisis,
you've got the housing bubble,
all these conventions.
Oh,
trust us,
we know what we're doing.
This is the thing,
the American dream is buying a home,
go to college,
take on that student loan debt.
Don't worry,
there's a job waiting for you.
Every single one.
These conventions from,
from all these people in power have not held up.
And so I think in particular,
millennials,
millennials look at that very skeptically cause we're like,
all right,
you know what?
So the conventional stuff didn't work out for anything.
Like we have no choice but to realize,
you know what,
we're all just hacking it.
So let's,
let's really,
let's dive into the passion.
Let's,
let's figure out a better way to do something.
Not Settle for the way it always been.
I think you're completely right.
And I think,
um,
first of all I'm slightly annoyed by this new statement and I'm forced to absorb
millennials.
I know it's terrible for you.
I'm sorry.
I'm not buying,
you can rebrand this.
I think we should,
I really do.
This is,
I think there's a divisiveness or there's a separation that comes when you start
labeling people by like what era they were born in.
It's a state of mind more than anything else.
Yeah,
I think so.
But I think it's horse shit,
generation x generation to fuck up.
It's just human.
It's like there's this idea of putting things in a label generalization.
The human brace is evolving.
Watch father knows best and then watch game of Thrones.
Okay,
shit's different now.
We don't have to come up with names for the generations and your generation y
and there was fucking Jamie from the laugh factory.
Tried to tell my friend,
uh,
Todd Parker,
Todd Parker's a standup comic that I started out with.
Jamie was like,
body,
you have to be generation x guy.
This is what you would do.
You'd go on stage and everything.
My generation,
generation x,
think that's going to be your hook.
And I remember him trying to explain it to change and I'm in the background
going,
did you hear what he told Tony to do?
What he tell tidy?
You must always wear a cowboy hat.
That was just thinking.
He would just look like woody from toy story cause he needed the hat.